Speaker 1: All right. Let's change gears
a little bit. Let me ask you a question.
Do any of you believe that Joe Biden is
running for reelection in 2024? I mean,
do any of you think that he is? I don't.
And this is my opinion. And I know that
it's considered sometimes inappropriate to say,
well, if he hasn't said he isn't running, David,
sir, you shouldn't really be saying it because you
might demoralize. I give you my opinion on this
show. My opinion is there is no sign whatsoever
that Joe Biden is running for reelection in 2024.
Kamala Harris recently had to walk back a
statement she made. Kamala Harris during an
interview said, Joe Biden is running and I will be
his running mate. And the next day she had to back
it up and say, well, actually, Joe Biden intends
to run. And when you keep hearing in tends to run.
And they go beyond that and say he's running and
then they've got to back it up and say that. What
I meant was he intends to run. Now that he
is running. It points to me that there is no
way Joe Biden is running for reelection. So let's
look at a couple of clips. Here is the first one.
This was an interview that Vice President
Kamala Harris gave to CNN and she sounded
very definitive early last week. Take a look.
Speaker 4: Joe Biden is running for reelection
and I will be his ticket mate.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Speaker 4: Full stop. Full stop.
Speaker 1: Right. Sounding incredibly confident.
And yet then she had to back it up. From The
L.A. Times, Vice President Harris says Biden
intends to run for reelection. This was two days
later. Vice President Kamala Harris created new
uncertainty Wednesday about President Biden's
intentions to run in 2024. Pulling back from
the definitive statement she made earlier
in the week, the president intends to run.
And if he does, I will be his ticket mate. We will
run together. We will run together. That is not
the confident statement that she made on Monday.
We have seen this language before. You might
remember that many times when former White House
press secretary Jen Psaki was asked, is Joe Biden
running for reelection because he hasn't declared
his candidacy? She would go with this phrase
intends to run. Here's just one example of that.
Speaker 2: Another round of stories over the
weekend about the political fate of the president
and the vice president and who might run in 2024.
And it quotes a lot of other Democrats
or people who work for them. What is the
White House's message to those Democrats?
Speaker 4: The White House is message,
as we're focused right now on what the American
people elected the president to do. Less about
just over a year ago, which is to get COVID
under control, to put people back to work
and to help give people some breathing room. And
we hope other people keep their focus on that
as well. Knock it off. Because that speculation.
The president has every intention of running for
reelection. So that's the other message for them.
Speaker 1: Every intention there is an intent to
run for reelection. Guys, I don't think Joe
Biden's running. And we very rarely on this
program talk about an election. That's not the
next one. The next one is in four in four months.
That's the one we would normally exclusively be
talking about. We have a very different situation
right now where I believe there is every sign that
Joe Biden is not going to run for reelection. He
would be 82 at the time of the next term. And it's
just not seeming to me like he's going to run.
His vice president, Kamala Harris, who would often
be the natural person to run if it is not the.
President himself is extraordinarily unpopular.
Kamala Harris As of right now, that could change.
But right now she's very unpopular. And there
are increased whisperings that Donald Trump
will soon be declaring his candidacy for 2024.
My belief at this point is Joe Biden, if he is
not going to run, should announce it sooner than
later, probably not before the November election.
It seems to me that it would be more prudent to
wait until the midterms and then for Joe Biden to
relatively quickly say, I am not going to run for
reelection. Why? If Donald Trump does declare or
he declares that he's not running and it's there
is a focus on DeSantis, as there increasingly is
or whatever. It seems like a bad recipe to have an
aggressive Republican candidate who has announced
they are running out. They're attacking Biden
and Biden, not planning to run, but not saying he
isn't planning to run. And Democrats just will be
weakened and weakened. And by the time Democrats
have a nominee, by the time Joe Biden says, I'm
not running, by the time it gets sorted out,
whoever is the strongest de facto candidate
on the Republican side has had months,
if not years, to prop themselves up and to
beat down on the Democratic Party and whoever
eventually intends to run. So unfortunately,
there's a bit of a reactive element where
if Trump says he's running or if Trump says he's
not and there are rumors he may do this soon,
I believe that is bad for whoever is the eventual
nominee, be it Joe Biden or not. And so if Biden
is not running, my belief is he should make that
known sooner than later, ideally not before the
midterms. Let me know your thoughts, whether you
agree or disagree. I want to hear from you. You
can find me on Twitter at David Pakman. And we'll
be back right after this. The David Pakman Show
is a community supported program. I invite you
to sign up on our website. Join Pacman dot com.
That's PR man. You can use the coupon code. Big
voting 22. That's what we need in November to get
a discount off of the cost of a membership. You'll
get the extra bonus show every single weekday.
You'll get a commercial free audio feed of the
show, a commercial free video feed of the show,
exclusive priority access to David
Pakman show audience, town halls
and The Daily Show. You will get up to 6 hours
earlier than we make it public for everybody.
A nice little set of benefits, I have to say.
And you can sign up at join Packman dot com.